in the last video we saw that if we had
an infinite series where each term is a
function of n and the function itself is
a continuous positive decreasing
function over the intervals that we care
about and we assume that this series
converges that we can estimate that
series we can just estimate that value
that it converges to using a finite
number of terms and some integrals and
the way that we establish these
integrals is because when we split up
the sum into a finite sum and then
another infinite series we're able to
conceptualize that infinite series in
two different ways it could be an
underestimate of this integral right
over here or it could be an overestimate
of this integral right over here and
because of that that allowed us not only
to estimate s but to put bounds on it if
we can evaluate the left-hand side here
and the right-hand side here for a given
infinite series then we can establish
our bounds on s and so let's see how
good these are by applying it to a
particular infinite series so let's say
let's say that the infinite series we
want to apply to
let me do it in the yellow color
so
it's
going to be let's say we go from n
equals 1 to infinity of 1 over n squared
let's say we didn't know how to find the
exact value here but we want to estimate
it and let's say we want to estimate it
using the first let's say we want to
estimate it using the first five terms
so we'll do s sub 5
is equal to the sum
the sum of n
equals 1
to
n sorry that equals 1 to 5
of 1 over n squared and let's see this
is going to be
this is going to be equal to let's get a
calculator out this is going to be 1
over 1 squared which is just 1 plus 1
over 2 squared which is 1 4
plus 1 over 3 squared which is 1 9
plus 1 over 4 squared which is 1 16
1 16 plus 1 over 5 squared which is
going to be 1
25th
1 25th and we get this value right over
here so i'll just say that this is i'll
say it's approximately 1.464
approximately 1.464
and then if we let's evaluate each of
these integrals so our k in this case is
going to be 5. i just picked that
arbitrarily we could probably get a
better or we would get a better estimate
if we had a higher k if we did the first
10 terms or 20 terms and we would have a
worse estimate if we did k equals 3 but
i just picked k equals 5 because it
seems reasonable something that we could
compute i actually didn't need a
calculator to do that i could have done
it by hand it would have just taken more
time let's evaluate these integrals here
so the integral from 5 plus 1 so it's 6
to infinity of 1 over n squared
dx
and
let's see that's going to be
that's going to be equal to let's write
it this way this is going to be the
limit we do all of it in blue actually
this is going to be equal to the limit
as
the limit as let's introduce a new
variable b approaches infinity
uh from of the integral from 6 to
infinity of 1 over n squared dx which is
equal to the limit
as b
approaches infinity
of
of
let's see the antiderivative of this is
negative negative n to the negative one
and we're going to evaluate that at b
and at six
so this is equal to the limit
as b
approaches infinity of negative one over
b negative one over b
minus negative one over six so plus
one over six
well as b approaches infinity this term
right over here goes to zero so this is
just going to be equal to one sixth
and we can use that exact same logic to
evaluate this integral so let's do that
actually so i'll do it right over here
so the definite the improper integral i
should say from and here we're gonna
evaluate not from six but from five
that's our k
5 to infinity of 1 over n squared dx
well the only difference here between
these two integrals is this bottom bound
this was 1 over 6 and by the same
arguments this one's going to end up
being 1 over
this one's going to be 1
over 5.
and so now we can put everything into
this compound equal inequality we're
going to have
1.464
1.464
plus this is i'm being a little bit
approximate here it's really this s sub
k which we have the exact value for in
our calculator
so it's 1.464
plus 1 6
plus 1 6
is less than or equal to
less than or equal to
is less than or equal to our sum which
we care about
which is less than or equal to 1.464
1.464 plus one-fifth
plus
one-fifth
and so this one is fairly
straightforward to calculate this is
going to be plus point two so this is
going to be less than or equal to
let's see one 1.264
so
sum is going to be less than or equal to
that
and on this side if we took
if we took our original expression and
then i added 1 6
one sixth
i get one point i get one let's see what
did i oh this is supposed to be one i
wrote this one wrong okay so this is
going to be
1.630 let me just write one point so
it's going to be one point six
three
oh and on this side
i wonder what my brain was
malfunctioning
this should be
one point
one i took away two instead of adding to
one point six six four
one
1.664
and so just like that you see okay this
thing must be like 1.6
you know it could be 1.63 something
could be 1.64 something could be 1.65
something it could be one 1.66 but this
is already giving us a lot of precision
if we only cared about things to the
tenths place this kind of we're done we
know it's going to be 1.6 something and
if we will go a little bit further this
is already giving us a lot of precision
and you can imagine if you added a few
more terms in in the partial sum you
would get even more precision so
hopefully you found this to be kind of a
neat exercise not only did we get a good
bit of precision a good bit of precision
with just taking a a partial sum in the
help of these integrals but we got a
good bound on it we know that the sum
that we're converging to is between
these two values